they talk about a sphere right and then
they give you some dimensions for its
radius Emily what's the radius of the
speed of 10 7.5 thank you what is that
centimeters yeah so you recognize this
as a question out surface area so you
dutifully go to the surface area formula
you punch in your numbers and I think
you get 705 something's every six and A
six there's a just keep going
yes sir whatever and that's it square
centimeters okay see what are the
surface area of this sphere then you
look at the question again it says how
many such spheres can I paint if I've
got enough paint to cover a square meter
is that one note entry is 10 is 10
square meters okay now just stay with me
for a second you've got a surface area
in these units and then you've got an
amount of paint in these units now the
units are not the same okay so I have a
bit of a challenge for myself I've got
to be able to convert between these and
then I have to try and match these
numbers together in the correct way okay
so here's my first question do I want to
change this into square centimeters or
do I want to change this into square
meters whatever you want to change this
one to square meters
okay how about changing who wants to do
this one - a square Sinemet yeah okay
hands down here's the thing right these
are units I can change them whichever
way I likes long as they're talking in
the same language it's fine however I'm
going to put in a vote to change this
one let me show you one if I were to
convert this into space enemies the
first thing I need to remember is it a
square B R he's a square meter is one
meter by one meter that's what a square
meter is by definition okay but then you
have to think about the conversion now
I'm going to a centimeter squared right
well the meter is 100
is do you agree and this leader is also
a hundred centimeters in debt so now to
think about this square it's a hundred
times 100 so this is back this is 10,000
square centimeters okay times 10 right
so therefore this is a hundred thousand
square centimeter that's how much paper
I've got right now some of you suggested
well what about this guy can I convert
this instead that's fine
we just do it in reverse I multiplied
this by 10,000 because I went for a
bigger to a small unit small unit is not
on them doesn't that make sense here I'm
going from a little unit to a big unit
so the number should get smaller because
there's not many of them really big
units so I'm gonna divide this by 10,000
instead of multiplying by 10,000 what is
this going to become there are four
zeros I'm gonna move right
so I think this is going to turn into
zero point zero seven or six eighths if
not I've ever done did I move it the
right number best wishes
one two three four I think I got it okay
now this is still true it's that is how
many square meters each one of my fears
is okay but if I have a choice about
which pair of numbers I have to use this
one and one that's in swimming or this
one and 100,000 I'm gonna choose the one
with like less we don't decimals in it
that's just easier to work with
okay so now here comes the question of
how to combine these he's how much paint
I thought he's how much each individual
sphere is I think most of us know that
there's some division involved right
this intelligently but the question is
do I divide this by this or do I divide
this by this okay so that number of
speeds is going to be the
not me here this is the number this is
the amount of paint I'm gonna split it
out across all these different spheres
did you get that this is the number that
gets split so to split a number you put
it at the front and then you're gonna
divide it by well that's how much each
one of them is now I don't know what
this is it's a hundred and something
okay now if you were to do this the
other way
if you did seven hundred six divided by
a hundred thousand you're going to get
like zero point zero zero seven or
something like that how many C's is that
not even a whole sphere that doesn't
make sense does it
I should be able to paint a whole bunch
of speeds okay so if for example we did
this the other way look at your answer
and think what's gone wrong something is
not quite right here because I can't
even pay a whole sphere and then that's
what they wants you to think I can
actually divide it wrong way around
does that make sense this is the way out
of frigate so a lot of people have asked
me a question for keep these confusing
but when you think about it slowly don't
don't jump to your calculator and also
please make sure you've got this on your
page if you're doing all the things in
your calculator if you get it right
first time then good for you but if like
most of us you're a little confused
you've got no work if you go back and
check on okay